avec nous robert rochefort bonjour
bonjour merci d'être sur le plateau d'
europe hebdo vous êtes député membre du
groupe adl le modem en france
enfin vous avez été élu sous les
couleurs de modèles vous êtes membre de
la commission du marché intérieur et des
consommateurs vous êtes économiste vous
allez nous expliquer un peu la portée de
toutes ces interventions de la banque
centrale européenne est ce que cette bce
seraient mises au service de la
croissance européenne
quel est son rôle il faut d'abord dire
merci à monsieur draghi
monsieur draghi est depuis quelques
temps le seul leader européen qui est à
la hauteur de la situation
mais il faut dire aussi qu'il est le
seul à la tête d'une institution
fédérale dont qui lui permet de faire
des choses donc mario draghi président
de la bce mario draghi président de la
bce ce qu'il fait est très bien il va
jusqu'au bout des limites possibles que
le traité lui permet mais soyons clairs
une politique monétaire est au service
favorise une politique de croissance
mais ne peut pas à elle toute seule
relancer la croissance est de la
responsabilité des états oui parce que
il ya deux sujets pour que la croissance
reparte en europe premièrement il faut
un plan d'investissement massif
alors c'est ce qu'on appelle ici le plan
juncker sur des grands investissements
qui concernent ni en europe et ce qu'il
est si massif que ça d'ailleurs parce
que oui il est quand même parler quand
même significatif il pourra être plus
élevé
vous savez que les états avaient la
possibilité de l'abonder en mettant de
l'argent supplémentaire mais aucun des
états n'a voulu faire ce qui au passage
me permets de vous dire que le troisième
facteur et qui par contre là manque
c'est une politique économique cohérente
entre les différents états tant que nos
politiques économiques ne sont pas
harmonisés et bien tout ça est un peu
freiné donc la bce fait beaucoup mais
c'est pas suffisant mais en tout cas
c'est trop déjà pour des pays comme
l'allemagne qui qui est redoutent que
cela doit leur nyala mauvais signal pour
les pelouses
indiqué on a l'exemple que je vous
indiquais il y a des divergences il y a
les faucons c'est l'allemagne
il y a les pays du sud qu'on se
considèrent souvent comme des pays
laxistes mais en deux mots qu'est ce que
fait la bce la bce pour la période tout
à fait récente vient de lancer ce qu'on
appelle le programme de quantitative
easing c'est à dire de rachat de dettes
pour une somme très très important de
toutes les dettes toutes les dates y
compris françaises sont à l'arrêt la
grecque il ne pourra pas la racheter
parce que la bce ne peut pas avoir à un
moment donné plus d'un tiers de la dette
publique d'un et d'un état dans ses
livres or là la grèce est déjà tellement
aidés a été tellement aidés que pour
l'instant c'est pas vers la grèce
pourrait faire cette précision quant à
la wii
alors sauf que si la grèce rembourse ses
échéances à court terme
elle pourra de nouveau prétendre puisque
une certaine façon alors à rembourser à
la bce elle pourra ré emprunter alors il
ya quelque chose qui peut paraître un
peu étrange mais c'est souvent comme ça
que ça marche
juste un mot quand même là la bce en
faisant ce rachat massif non seulement
un site à ce que l'argent reste pas cher
oui normalement ça permet à l'économie
de repartir quand il y a des projets
mais encore faut-il que des projets mais
aussi elle est dans son rôle puisque
vous savez contrairement aux reportages
qui était indiqué l'objectif de la bce
c'est c'est pas de ne pas avoir d'
inflation du tout c'est d'avoir une
inflation de 2 2 % en quinze jours du
lit ce qui nous menace c'est la
déflation en europe
la déflation c'est à dire une inflation
négative et ça c'est le pire des
cauchemars
alors elle rachètera massivement ses
dettes publiques mais avec l'espoir que
les acteurs économiques les banques les
entreprises et les consommateurs
puissent emprunter ou investir mais
encore faut-il que les banques jouent le
jeu
encore faut-il surtout qui la dette
publique a racheté c'est ça qui est un
peu le paradoxe c'est que les banques
puisque vous en parlez les banques
aujourd'hui on de la dette publique des
différents états mais les banques ont
besoin de placer dans des danses qu'on
appelle des emprunts qui sont sûres or
les dettes d'état aujourd'hui sont sûrs
et les banques finalement reçoivent
aujourd'hui une rémunération qui est
quand même significatif pour ses dettes
d'état
donc l'idée de la bcc de racheter cette
dette des états mais quand ses dettes et
déjà placées auprès des banques
il n'est pas sûr que les banques
effectivement donne cette dette
en réalité ce que fait aussi la bce
c'est très important c'est qu'elle donne
un signal psychologique et politique de
confiance elle dit elle dit on est là et
on soutiendra les chances mais vous avez
raison les banques ne vont peut-être pas
du coup récupérer de l'argent auprès de
la bce a pour placer dans l'économie
mais ce n'est pas vraiment complètement
de la faute des banques c'est de la
faute de ses politiques économiques qui
ne sont pas assez intégrés et surtout de
ce plan d'investissement dont j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure qui est un plan dans
lequel nous avons beaucoup d'espoir mais
reconnaissons le qui n'est pas encore
aujourd'hui très concret et très
opérationnel alors un petit mot très
vite de commentaires sur ce nouveau
délai accordé à la france par bruxelles
qui lui donne donc deux ans de plus pour
espérer rentrer dans les clous du pacte
de stabilité écouter le commentaire de
pierre moscovici le commissaire aux
affaires économiques
les réformes entreprises depuis deux ans
vont dans la bonne direction mais dans
le contexte actuel
elles n'ont pas encore suffi à corriger
cette situation
sachant que l'objectif de 3% n'est pas
atteignable en 2015
il fallait prendre une nouvelle
recommandation
ce sera fait dans les jours qui viennent
avec une trajectoire de retour vers 3% à
l'horizon 2017 soit un délai de deux ans
supplémentaires qui va exiger des
efforts importants de la part de la
france c'est très clair et la commission
sur ce point est tout à fait exigeante
alors deux ans de plus à la france ce
qu'ils amènent à 2010 est allé
électorale est ce que vous pensez qu'il
y aura des qu'il pourrait y avoir des
sanctions si elles ne respectent pas je
suis triste pour mon pays la france
parce que vous voyez bien que ce que
nous demande bruxelles en l'occurrence
c'est pas quelque chose qui est fait
pour faire plaisir à bruxelles c'est
quelque chose qui est importante pour
notre pays
plus nous retardons et là c'est la
troisième fois qu'on retarde plus ils y
ont même que nous pénalisons vous voyez
bien parce que là il va falloir faire
quoi cette année 4 milliards d'économies
budgétaires supplémentaires parce qu'on
les a pas fait dans les années
précédentes
alors il ya là ça m'a contraint de la
croissance alors il ya la loi macron qui
est actuellement toujours en examen au
parlement européen que le gouvernement a
dû à du mal à faire passer d'ailleurs
est ce que ça ne suffit pas pour
bruxelles pour vous savez ce que c'est
qu'un escargot savez l'escargot c'est ce
petit animal et il a une coquille comme
ça c'est à dire si on prend l'escargot
par l'extérieur on a l'impression qu'on
tourne autour du pot comme si rapproche
que lentement tournant et c'est la loi
macron c'est comme les réformes
insuffisantes que nous en fait jusqu'à
présent c'est à dire on va vers
l'objectif central donc mais on y va
extrêmement lentement en sainte
on ne s'attaque pas à la chose la plus
importante pour conclure cette émission
quelle est pour vous la réforme
prioritaires à mener en france pour il y
en a il y en à l'essentiel porte sur le
marché du travail
assouplissement contrat contrat de
travail unique
en contrepartie m l'argent de la
formation professionnelle au service des
chômeurs c'est ci pourrait être quelque
chose de gagnant gagnant et une réforme
une simplification considérable du droit
du travail comme idée
i du code du travail et des seuils
salariaux en particulier de 50 qu'ils
soient remis en cause parce que on sait
très bien que c'est un obstacle à la
croissance de l'activité économique en
france et c'est ça dont on a absolument
besoin et on n'en n'a pas fini d'en
parler merci beaucoup robert rochefort
avec nous